das holodeck kommt für audio 3d kino ist
schnee von gestern dreidimensionale
musik ist das neue unterhaltungsmedium
also nicht 1 7 zu 1 oder 5 zu 1
soundsystem sondern eben noch ein ganzes
stück mehr wie das geht und was ich
damit alles anstellen lässt jetzt in
clips als fiktiv
mit mpeg h wird die tonwiedergabe
revolutioniert zum ersten mal wird es
möglich sein töne instrumente stimmen
geräusche und so weiter im raum zu
positionieren jeder mensch wird im raum
etwas anderes als alle anderen also die
zuschauer würden mitten zb im orchester
stehen es ist das holodeck für audio
wenn wir heute schon schallquellen
zwischen zwei kanälen von rechts nach
links oder umgekehrt wandern lassen
können ist es eben mit der neuen
technologie möglich sie überall zu
positionieren entwickelt haben die
technologie wissenschaftlerinnen
wissenschaftler des fraunhofer instituts
für digitale medientechnologie in
ilmenau kurz idee mt
das fraunhofer institut hatte ja schon
mp3 entwickelt dass er die ganze musik
industrie umgekrempelt hat jetzt kommt
also die nächste revolution
aber wie geht das genau
der ursprung der technologie liegt weit
in der vergangenheit zurück im jahr 1678
notierte der physiker christian rickens
die wellenfeldsynthese diese besagt dass
egal um welche art von wellenfront es
sich handle
diese mit schallwellen interferenzen
produziert werden könne
ende der 80er jahre des letzten
jahrhunderts fand professor buße tut
dann folgendes heraus ein sogenanntes
räumliches wellen fällt entsteht bei der
interferenz von schallwellen das heißt
mit den einzelnen angepassten wellen
kann man das wellen feld räumlich
steuern im jahr 1678 oder eben ende der
80er letzten jahrhunderts war das
technisch nicht zu realisieren
heute ist es möglich geworden
leistungsstarke computer können hoch
komplizierte algorithmen berechnet und
eben genau diese können dass wellen
fällt bzw
die schallwellen ausgabe aus
lautsprecherboxen bestimmen
in der praxis sieht das folgendermaßen
aus ihr müsst euch einen raum vorstellen
in dem mehrere boxen rund 100 stück und
ein pass ab wo vor um euch herum
befestigt sind das heißt an der wand
hängen lautsprecher an lautsprechern
lückenlos alle sind mit einem computer
verbunden auf dem computer ist eine
software installiert die mpk
musikformate so auf die boxen verteilt
wie ihr es gerne hättet kleine neben
impfung mit einem mpeg audio layer 3
also einem mp3 format würde das nicht
gehen da dieses auf eine dafür sehr
niedrig und damit um brauchbare kanal
anzahl beschränkt ist die software
steuert also die musik die schallwellen
ausgabe dann gebt ihr noch ein paar
infos zu dem raum in dem ihr euch
befindet ein und schon kann es losgehen
hier steht jetzt sagen wir mal in der
nördlichen hälfte des zimmers da ihr fan
von instrumentaler musik seit wollt ihr
die sängerin oder den sänger nicht hören
ihr wollt nur die instrumente hören
einfach einstellen
eure freundin oder freund der sitzt auf
der couch der in der anderen hälfte des
zimmers steht und möchte die ganze musik
inklusive sängerin oder sänger hören
auch das könnt ihr dann einfach
einstellen ohne dass er dann wieder den
gesang hört sensationell
dabei wird halt nicht mehr der schall
aus den lautsprechern konkret gehört
sondern das schallwellen fällt am
jeweiligen standort so kann durch die
lautsprecher und ihre wellen
überlagerung an verschiedenen orten
mitten im raum ein völlig
unterschiedliches hörerlebnis geschaffen
werden ich habe mir das selbst war
angehört und das ist absolut
beeindruckend
du hörst nicht die richtung aus der der
schall kommt sondern wirklich zum
beispiel eine geige die direkt neben dir
stehen so hörte sich jedenfalls an
absolut dame
mit der wellen synthese gibt es
zahlreiche neue möglichkeiten im kino
könnten filme in unterschiedlichen
sprachversionen zur selben zeit und im
selben saal abgespielt werden
auf messen könnten auf einer bühne zwei
vorträge parallel abgehalten werden gut
das ist jetzt vielleicht etwas seltsame
idee aber die ganze technologie kann
nicht nur zu unterhaltungszwecken gehen
sie kann auch zur sicherheit im
straßenverkehr beitragen
der verkehrsfunk dem bekommt dann die
oder derjenige am steuer zu hören und
der rest im auto die musik der fahrer
oder die fahrerin wird nicht mehr durch
laute musik abgelenkt diese
möglichkeiten sind zwar noch ein
bisschen fiktiv aber die ersten mpk
geräte könnte es schon 2020 zu kaufen
geben so sieht es zumindest christoph
sladek satte check ist in der
glücklichen lage in einem sogenannten
wave studio in ilmenau sitzen und
arbeiten zu dürfen also die technologie
funktioniert dass es fakt ist auch dass
mit mpk wiedergegebene musik sowie mp3
einen enormen einfluss auf die
unterhaltungsindustrie haben kann
musik hat eine so große bedeutung für
uns da sie sex ml jedenfalls so wie sie
sich auf unseren körper auswirkt mehr
dazu erfahrt ihr im video hier oben
unter mids sap und zum block kommt ja
auch über sie und lass uns noch mal ganz
fiktiv in den kommentaren diskutieren
was ihr für technologien noch gerne
hättest was wünscht ihr euch für die
zukunft sehr und dann kann ich nur sagen
bis dann bleib dran